Long ago, there lived a lonely old carpenter named Geppetto.
He made a puppet out of some wood, a ball, and a string.
That night, a fairy visited and cast a spell that made the puppet walk and talk.
Geppetto named him Pinocchio.
Geppetto gave Pinocchio some money and sent him into town to buy schoolbooks.
Instead, Pinocchio spent the money on a circus ticket.
The fairy asked him what he did with the money and he lied to her.
Suddenly, his nose grew.
The fairy said, "Whenever you lie, your nose will get bigger."
"Now go find Geppetto."
"He's out looking for you by the sea."
Pinocchio was rowing a small boat in the sea and found Geppetto inside a whale.
Pinocchio made the whale sneeze and they escaped.
Relieved, he promised to never lie again.
The fairy said, "Keep that promise and I will turn you into a real boy."